What about you Red? What you want?
Red knows better to nerf you as soon now.
Just operates up a plate and just like quickly give me some.
Whatever you got he'll take it.
Red be waffles.
I'm going to just let him up some food and then I'm going to start cleaning my pan.
Okay.
All right. So you eat your breakfast and you clean up your utensils.
You put them in your carry on or whatever you have.
And then the other players do the other characters do not see this but within the armor.
Staplea takes a single bite of cheese and then she is full.
She's going to keep the cheese and the lids finished.
Yeah, this she will probably last like a fucking week.
And then you will mouth and I'm just kidding.
And then she will go and gather up whatever supplies they can go and sell from this place.
Okay, let me give you what it's inside.
Let me roll some stuff on the.
I want to get myself some heavy armor a sad.
For the six.
Sorry, sorry.
It's here.
You look over.
Hey, there was some stuff in that tent. You might want to check it out.
I took all the ingredients of food, but you might want to check that out too.
You might find 17 pellets of bullet that you can put into any of your weapons if you have any.
If you don't, then that's fine.
You find.
One armor set.
Yeah, one armor set that you can use to, you know, do something with the rest is either like broken or.
Rusted or something.
Like like is it heavy armor light armor heavy armor.
What kind of heavy armor.
You know, I've seen in one piece like theirs.
Some.
The kind of armors in dress Rosa kind of those armors like the metal armors.
Like is it chain mail.
Yeah, chain mail with helmets.
Some boots and stuff.
The rest of the rest is.
Let me see eight armors.
I just leather armors, which I don't think you can use much just for selling.
Oh, perfect.
I think that's exactly what I hate the chain mail armor.
Yeah.
I'm just going to say this.
What what they don't know is the meal I just prepared them was that crawfish dude into the eggs.
Well,
we ate the cheese.
Is this technically cannibalism?
I think it is.
I feel like it is.
No, he was it was a fish man fish and fish men very different.
I guess it would be like if you consider humans and humans and fish men to be like a set to the same race or minks and fish men to be the same species.
I think it is.
I think it is morally.
Morally.
Yes, definitely cannibalism.
But if you're getting.
If you're.
I guess it wouldn't be considered cannibalism.
He would definitely taste like a crawfish.
Yeah, and y'all didn't question it.
I mean, I didn't know I find you I would have told them to roll for something.
Well, and you find.
Find four.
Schmidt tires as well.
If you want to take those as well.
Yeah, what are you saying?
What is red what is red fine and heard his tent, my best.
I'm saying like for the whole.
I don't this is all they get.
Okay, that they can either carry or you know, scalbush basically the rest is maybe useless for the most part.
They take everything.
I told you, but I told you it's all your guys is so it's up to you guys.
I'm going to make my fat ass.
Which way is the not.
It should be down the down.
I've had a.
Waddle down here.
Can I be looking for like ingredients to like.
Yeah, keep keep doing some perception checks or whatever.
I'll let you know what you find.
Give me like three as you walk around give me like three perception checks and I'll tell you what you find.
I mean, it's just words you probably didn't just find some herbs lying around.
That's probably it.
Oh, 16. That's pretty good.
Yeah, you go around you find some herbs that you haven't seen before you maybe try those in some recipes.
Damn.
You find an end.
I don't know what you want to do with the end mode, but okay.
I'll go ahead and make this.
You find a couple of bird eggs in one of those trees.
I don't know if you want to take them or no, but that's.
I'm taking everything.
Eggs can be used. That's protein right there.
All right, exactly.
Something goes on within the armor as it seems like the off the chain mail is integrated into the giant dive into as additional armor played in.
Basically, she's making this she's making this chain mail into her new arcane armor.
For now, just add like whatever AC chain mail gives you to your AC and you have to and equip the older armor or shield whatever you have before.
I'm going to do that right now.
So should we move to where you guys going next?
We going back to the end to pick up Lynn.
All right, let me move you guys to the broken go.
I just just follow up with like whatever a sets of leather armor, basically just a pile of leather with legs walking.
You need some help carrying that.
I wasn't going to help. I got to look for food for you guys.
Okay, what you ask.
All right, you see just the bar keeper and Lynn just sitting on the.
What is it called?
Because it's pretty early. No one said the in right now.
Perfect. I'm going to ask a barkeep if I can make some food for him to sell and I make money off of it.
So you're going to spend the whole day here.
Well, no, it's going to take me 45 minutes while they're discussing business. Well, the bar keeps getting go.
Well, most of our customers don't show before like the evening.
So it really is an worth much if you cook right now.
Well, if you got a pig, I can make you some ribs. I could start smoking. I mean, you could just pull them off and get.
And then I'll go back into the kitchen.
Whatever.
I was up there. Yeah, back there. Yeah.
You can do whatever there.
Lynn's just sitting there. So he's like, you've decided to show up here.
So what's the plan here?
Where's the little guy that you had?
He has decided that he is not cut out for the pirates life.
So it's too bad, isn't it? Okay. Let me tell you what I'm going to grab my stuff and move it to the ship.
I remember you asked for some some place to get some supplies.
Unfortunately, again, this is just a small island. You probably won't find much.
But near the rocks, there should be some shops.
So you should be able to find some things that depends.
Not probably anything for combat or anything, but maybe some healing stuff. Sure.
I'm going to go get myself and load it onto your ship. I'll see you on your ship. And then Lynn lives.
Well, do you want to go shopping reddit?
Yes. I haven't a clue yet.
So you want to go to the dogs.
As you enter the dogs, the sweet earthy scent of trees, apps, or does fills your lungs as you step off the planks.
Wouldn't platforms creek underfoot strung between massive amber stain trees that stretch above up high above workers bustle around the dogs rolling barrels stacking crates of resin and lacquered bound goods.
And then you miss the moment you see one figure stands apart all still wings stuck neatly behind him like a shadow held at bay arms crossed cloaks swinging slightly in the warm breeze he waits with the stillness of someone who used to be standing alone.
And as soon as you see him, you kind of recognize him. You've only seen him once, but you know who he is.
And then you move you guys to the scene, but Roma, you have suck back. I don't know when you will come here, but please show up.
Yeah, exactly. You know what happens.
I'm not sure if I'm a little bit more of a woman.
All right, that piece to your, your cue, you're here.
Hello.
The dread not the dread not slowly marches up to the winged man also or a farm in herself.
All right, thanks. Everyone's a little far away.
In due to four I am the dread not.
He just moves.
You're a dread not. Stop here. You're dead. He's left.
Well, I will get your way that I have places to be.
Actually, the orders involved you.
Make sure you handle Kira properly.
Well, we already did that yesterday.
That include eating him.
And then you know, I'm not going to silence it in the art. There's a moment of silence in the armor.
I'm having no. I was in the forest watching. You did eat him.
You didn't know this. This is your first time knowing that you actually ate the guy.
I don't know. That's a thing. Sappily I did not eat any meat.
Red is looking more and more distressed as he kind of realized.
I don't know if he's going to eat it.
I'm not going to eat it.
Sappily a little pat red's head.
You're forming a very interesting crew.
So I'll be watching.
My body tries to kill me every day. Still still fails after 19 years.
Take off the helmet and let's see how true that is.
You can see a bunch of shops near the edge of the dogs.
But most of them just either have like a bunch of tree amber, like rubber materials and all that.
You see one shop that has some kind of like makeshift board and just a bunch of marine stuff lying around.
Sappily I will say very well.
She will put her she will raise up her arms and put them all on her helmet as steam vents.
And she just pops off her helmet.
Hi there, Baptiste.
Hello, Sappily.
I'm still still be at an edge, Lord, I see.
Still funny.
She's been alive.
Black hand to give you orders to black, white, black hand to give you orders to actually make some friends now.
Oh, yeah, this is what I look like red.
Sappily looks down with her tiny, with her tiny blonde head down at red.
As I was just saucers.
You took off your head.
Oh, it's a helmet.
I just keep it I just keep it on for the cool factor.
And then I just keep it on for the cool factor.
This is a dive and see.
The catable and now, Sappily, it's not a robot.
The world has shattered.
Sappily is not at all opposed to take it off her helmet.
She was just waiting for someone to ask.
After a moment, Sappily will slot her helmet back in.
Well, we were just about, we were just getting ready to leave this island.
And then to head to Ampricrat, not to head to, there it is.
We're going to be getting a new ship there.
If you saw that online, but you couldn't get a pretty good one too.
Absolutely, no way.
I knew that you wouldn't have crossed.
But orders are orders.
So, wherever you go.
I have to go.
Actually, have you heard from, have you heard from Blockhand recently?
I've been flying for over a week now, so I haven't had the chance to try and make touch with basics.
I left.
Yeah, that's where I tried calling him yesterday, but there was no response from the first fleet.
I also, I called Miran, there was, and she said that they didn't get a response from Blackhand either.
Whatever was going on there was pretty hectic too from what I can tell.
Whatever it is, Blackhand should be fine.
All right.
Sorry.
You got another, you got a new guy coming along with us.
That's to you, but please.
It's Linus.
He turns out he also has business at Sphere Closed.
So, he's coming along with us.
Is Doctor.
Yep, he's coming along.
Looks like you know how to make a crew after all.
I won't be able to get to the Grand Line without making one.
We won't get this damn in Kereba.
We'll get this done after you.
Onward.
Sadly, it begins marching, marching off to look for a Linus.
Okay, Linus is probably on the ship.
Okay, then she'll be gone for, she'll be gone to look for a Roma.
Wait, you read the doctor, aren't you, weren't you here to buy stuff?
Oh, yeah.
Well, you see, sapling about distracted.
Yeah, that's why.
Sapling will look down at red and say, oh, you want to explore around here, see if there's anything neat to buy?
Or red still looks like very unsure.
I'm not sure if you see a real face yet.
Alrighty then.
She's also not at all doing the fake voice anymore.
Yeah, I see.
All you see is like again, a bunch of shops that have nothing to do with that can help you.
Essentially, it's just clanks wood, laying around, sap, tree sap, rubber, stuff, and all that.
She's a little bit around now that has some marine equipment on it, like some, what do you say, pistols, some weapons, a couple of them, not a lot.
But it seems like that's the only place where you can find anything.
All right, is there a toy shop?
Over there probably, like, be some carving shops, wood carvings.
Perfect.
Sapling a little march on towards one of those carving shops.
How can I help you?
You see an old woman at the shop?
I see that you sell wood carvings here.
Oh, yes, nearly. What can I help you with?
Can you tell me about these wood carvings?
Well, we got the white admiral carvings. We got the maw.
We got the garb, the hero. We got one more, but nobody knows about them.
We got Suru. We have some captains too, if you want to hear about them.
Sappelea will look to the garb figure.
Who is this?
Don't you know, it's the new admiral, the white admiral that is going to become the admiral.
It's the garb, the hero, of the marine.
Well, let's see. He is a white admiral, but he is about to become an admiral.
So he would fetch a big price.
I'd say about 300,000.
300,000 per year for a wood carving.
Yep.
Nice insight.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
Yes, Sappelea will also insight that.
That is just standing there. Let's see.
200,000.
You're like, what the fuck?
You're rolling privately.
Click on "Pubrik Roll" and then roll again.
You can see your roll.
Okay, okay, okay. That's good.
You can tell that she has seen you guys from afar talking and she also noticed as dreadnought
left their ship yesterday.
Both Sappelea and Baptiste can tell that what's happening.
So, yeah.
Sappelea is just locked in.
She's like, I want that figure.
Don't fuck with me.
So essentially, she knows that you're part of the Black Hand crew.
And everyone in the east is aware of Black Hand.
So she's just trying to hustle you.
400,000 peris is a steep price for a simple wood carving.
Well,
maybe we can do 150,000.
How about that?
Just for you, Deary.
Sappelea places her armoured hands on her knees as she bends down to get more to face level
with the old woman.
It says.
I think it's an idiot despite the order.
What do you mean this is this is a general price?
Can you roll for intimidation?
All right.
You're fucking going.
You're going to give this woman a hard attack if you roll too much.
Okay.
That's only a nine.
It's only a nine.
But it's better than that for the old woman.
She's like, okay, okay.
I will give you a fair price.
I was just trying to make some money.
You know, we don't get much in our year.
I got to send my grandkids to college, you know.
How about what?
Actually,
I'm going to send them wood figure and pick it up and look under it to see if there's like a price tag on the bottom of them.
Yeah, do that.
Give me.
Can you give a slide a pen?
Oh, she's not being slight about it.
She is just looking towards running, picking one up.
No one can really stop you.
So yeah, you look inside the, look, look at the bottom of the figures, one of the figures of the same size.
Let's say you pick up any other wise admirals, right?
It would say something like 50K, around 50K.
50K barriers.
So yeah, it's a lot of different kinds of things.
And it's a lot of different kinds of things.
It's a lot of different kinds of things.
Maybe some med kids and all that.
50,000 for the leather armor.
I'll take that off your hand.
For the smitters.
I'll give you 100,000.
They seem pretty new.
That's a deal.
150,000.
I'll take this stuff out your hand.
and that's all he takes all this stuff and he will give you one hundred fifty thousand you can add that in pure berries.
All right we switch back to.
If he had like studded leather armor like some kind of upgrade for RIS then I'd be interested by the way it's the latest move on.
Okay no no you wanna buy stuff yeah sure go ahead what you want.
studded leather armor.
Let me see.
Steady to do.
Man studded leather armor.
Okay you see armor at the back of the shop and you kind of like it and you say okay how much is that.
The shop keep will go.
Hmm let's see how about fifty thousand.
Essentially an exchange for all of your leather armors for this one this is this is pretty good new stuff.
Hi please and just kind of drops the armor on the counter.
I'm gonna drop the leather armor into your inventory.
You can equip that one over.
Yay.
Anything else you're looking for?
That's it.
All right let's switch back to Sapya.
So what are you guys doing now?
You're still haggling over the price.
Yeah.
Sapya will now begin looking over the captain figures.
You see one of the captains is just they have a repair in their hand and from the looks of it like the way the word is carved you see that they're like the their hair is probably all blonde.
And they have like a very noble manner of their standing all that.
None of the other captains seem that notable.
All right.
So look at the bottom of this.
This one will say around hundred thousand but it will say a star at the end.
All right she'll look at just some known name captains price men.
You see one of the captains with like just a top hat and those have like twenty thousand behind beneath them.
Hey you stop.
I told you to not look at those.
I'm running a business here get out.
Then I shall buy this one.
She holds up one of the known name captains figures.
Okay.
See then I go.
Okay for you for being this rude give me thirty thousand okay.
It's the root tax.
All right I think the twenty thousand please.
She will place that twenty twenty thousand there for it.
All right.
This is it.
This did not that.
I would have gone nineteen ninety nine.
I just said the word go and contacts it.
I'm texting you for long.
All right anything else you want to do at the dogs.
Is that it?
She'll also have the question of color marine shop.
All right.
Red is there and tap the I just walks behind her.
I'll be in him and now you're there too.
What are you doing?
More customers.
What do you need?
What kind of armor do you sell here?
Well we got your standard marine armor.
We got there's leather stuff.
We got the better leather stuff and we got some chain mail.
Some war and can be heard within the within the armor of saffoli as a set of scales
and some more armor dispenses from it and have the sense I would like to sell this.
Oh God.
Sure.
I'd say 75,000 leave you to take it.
I don't want your shit.
Okay.
I only have this much money.
She'll, she plops it down.
All right.
Rift this, rift this random dude.
It just seems a normal armor to him.
He just pulls it out and just puts it back on one of his displays.
That damn it.
No one wants to buy my stuff all they only do is just sell this.
I need to move to some bigger city man.
This is crazy.
And what supplies do you sell here?
Oh, okay.
Finally, fucking lock in.
Lock in.
Okay.
Yeah.
We have some tone dials.
We have some med kits that we got from some Marines and we got some you know pistols.
We got some short bows and all of that.
Yes.
Tell me what you need.
I can help you with it.
For sure.
Can you show me your toe dials?
Oh, we got, we got a recording tone dial.
We got an air tone dial.
It, it shoots out air.
That's all it does.
We got some, what are the fuck?
Let me open up my sheet.
I just posted in the corner in this new farmer.
We got, we got a flame dial.
We got a light dial which, which flashes in the night.
We got a heat dial.
If you throw this and turn it on, you can heat up like a pan or like you know, just boil
water essentially.
We got a jet dial, but I don't think that was that going to help you.
He looks at how huge you are.
I think that's going to help you.
We got a water dial.
We got milk dial.
You can dispense milk from it.
I don't know what kind of milk it is though.
So be careful.
That's it, that's all he has.
Out of spite.
Sappily I will say how much would be the jet dial?
The jet dial uses like very flammable stuff.
So it costs a lot of money.
Are you sure you want to throw because I don't think it will help you?
I will find a way.
All right, how many do you need?
One.
Oh, one.
That's going to be a hundred thousand batteries.
Some more where and can be heard inside of the armor as a hundred thousand dispenses
from it.
Right.
He pulls out one of the dials.
It's just marked with like black marker and it says jet on it.
And it just sends it just gives you that.
Well, thank you for your business.
Are you sure this works?
Oh, yeah, it definitely works.
I'll give you a money back if it doesn't work.
Come here at any point.
Sappily I will place the jet dial in one hand and place her other hand in front of it
as to so it doesn't like shoot off into the wall or something.
Okay.
And it's up to the test this dial.
As soon as you click on the dial, propulsion starts going.
We need the dial, but it does not move because the amount of pressure you're holding it with
is far lesser than it can help you.
It can push against against basically.
Yeah, it's just floats.
Sappily making sure it doesn't like fly off.
Yeah, it just stays in place and it just runs out at one point and it just dies.
Thank you for your business.
You just wasted that dial.
All right.
Sure.
Okay.
The guy at the shop will look at Roma and that piece.
What can I help you with, sir?
I'm going to turn to my buddy and be like, what the fuck is a dial?
So Sappily, you can tell them about the dials.
If you know, can you give me a history?
Would you actually know?
She might have heard about them, but Y'all rule that history check.
No, I don't know what history check.
Yeah, she might have heard about them.
I mean, if you're like, yeah, I'll say you know about them.
If you're like, you know, artificially, you probably know about tone dials.
Yeah, Sappily, I will say dials hail from sky islands within the grand line.
They, let me, let me double check my own dial knowledge so I don't start.
Essentially, they're like seashells, but they have like, I don't know what kind of technology
it is, but they like do, they like essentially store stuff inside them.
It can be audio.
It can be any kind of material.
Are they?
They have to be.
Most of them is one time, but the recording ones and the audio ones, they can be used again
and again.
They are one time use, but they can also be refilled.
Yeah.
So you record an audio and you play it.
I think you can record it again or I don't know how it exactly works, but it's like a
two time use.
No, no, you can use them as long as you can refill them.
Yeah.
So Sappily is going to be studying how she can refill this dial here.
Well, shit, if I get the one that lets me boil water, will you hold on to it for me?
I don't mind.
For the boil water one, I'd say it just heats up.
So I don't think that we need refilling.
What the fuck, we need refilled the fire, put it in the flame and it would recharge.
Probably some.
Yeah.
Okay.
It probably, but it also probably takes a while to recharge our MPO true.
So are you going to buy the heat one?
How much is it?
The heat one is pretty common.
So I'd say 75,000.
35,000.
Yeah.
If it's coming, it's not common.
It comes from sky islands.
Do you think it's common?
You just said it's pretty common.
It's pretty common considering the dial.
Yeah, you just told me right from my 100.
But what I'm saying is you just said that.
Well, I felt bad.
They just wasted it.
But you just said that one was rare for a 100.
Okay.
I'm calling the S.
Hey, look, man.
I'm just trying to make some money here.
Are you going to buy stuff or no?
I am.
I'll give you 50k.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Seems you don't know.
You can refill these dials.
Look, man.
I'm not a fucking scientist.
Do whatever you want with it.
All right, Tapley.
You hold on to that for me.
When I need a cook, I'll let you know.
He's going to look at Baptiste and he's going to say, "Do you want to rape me off too?"
You're talking to me?
Yeah.
What?
What are you here?
He's going to best be on him.
All right.
Good to do an intimidation.
He's going to go.
You know what?
I actually have to leave.
Can you guys go away now?
And he's trying to close up shop, essentially.
I'd say it's almost like maybe around 10, 11 a.m. in the morning.
What's your plan now?
Get on the ship.
Let's get the fuck out of here.
All right.
Have everyone.
That's a lot of work.
That's my vote.
I'll do whatever.
I don't think we have anything else in particular unless we want to buy more supplies.
Well, the guy kind of closed up shop on us.
I mean, he's closing.
You can still stop him.
You can try to look around for more stuff.
Do you need anything else?
I'm good to go unless you need to stop a ship with food.
No, I already did that.
Remember?
Yeah, he told the barkeep to load up the ship.
It's probably loaded.
Yeah, I think we're good.
I'd say about 10 days of ration.
He's already on the ship.
All right.
10.
That will.
25,000.
Again, it's like normal fish and all that.
It's pretty common considering everything is just water.
I'm going to be making food.
We're talking sushi.
We talking.
Can Sapoia study the map to guesstimate how long it would take to.
That's tough.
I don't know which one of you would probably the best.
I think Baptiste would be the best person to know where stuff is.
I think it's a good one.
Maybe leave it to them or if you want to run it, then you can run it too.
Do nature.
Yeah.
I am good at nature.
I am not.
18.
Nature would be probably for the weather mostly, but I want to want to see.
I don't know it for the whole journey.
But for now, it looks pretty clear.
She's not studying the work.
She's not studying the weather.
The map that Sora left for.
I asked.
I asked how well asked if she could guesstimate how long it would take to get to spirit lift.
Okay.
Let me check.
What check would that be?
You don't have any navigator stole so that I can do it.
Would that be history?
I guess it would be history.
Just run a history.
All right.
Damn.
Holy shit.
All right.
I guess you could more or less tell that it's maybe a three day journey.
There's spirit clips.
All right.
Sap way over looked about teeth and say, well, can you navigate a ship then?
We sort of lost.
We.
We just need.
We're not trying to look at the direction we need to know.
So we're just looking at the direction you want to go or.
That's it.
All right.
Well, Sap way will take out the supplies she was given by a.
Sora before he left for navigation.
All right.
Let me open up the fucking mouth.
Okay.
Let me.
Can you guys see this?
The map.
Yeah.
Okay.
You're at amber crest here.
Ignore the rest of the stuff.
The area that you see at the bottom here.
This model island.
That's spirit clips.
It's not labeled or anything.
It's just at the bottom of the map.
You can see one of the depictions in the map shows like seeking attacks in between this area.
So you have to be careful of that.
Other than that, I think it's pretty straightforward.
If you just chart the coast to like Southwest.
South.
Yes, Southwest.
You'll get there in three days.
Alrighty.
Well, it looks like we'll have to be going do Southwest to make it to spirit cliff.
All right.
Everybody ready?
Yes.
All right.
Take your positions.
Lynn is already on the ship.
And he's going to be like.
Okay.
So.
Let me get this.
We want to sell the ship.
Two three days in an area where there's a ship.
Yeah, where there's probably sea kings.
And we don't have an navigator.
Do you know how to navigate?
No.
I can't be everything.
I know how to fix people.
That's all I do.
Okay.
But all right.
I guess, I guess we leave it up to the sea.
I can.
I can pick this up pretty quickly.
I safely old up the map.
Also, this is the first time line.
It was also the first time a Linus and Roma have heard.
Saffelia used her actual voice instead of her fake ass voice.
I do.
Yeah.
Roma.
Roma is probably seeing you in and out of the thing.
Yeah.
I think she's not going to be able to see you.
She's not going to be able to see you.
She has never been out of her honor.
Oh, that is true.
Okay.
But I would have heard the voice at some point.
When Lin uses the emergency triad, whatever his thing is,
he actually phases through people's bodies.
And then jump starts their hearts, essentially.
So he probably knows what you look like.
And then he's not brought it up because it doesn't matter to him.
Yeah, I don't, I don't know what you look like.
I just know what you sound.
Yeah.
How do I say?
Saffelia is now trained to be a navigator along with being the captain.
About that.
Can I look to make sure he's holding the map the right way?
Yeah.
She knows how to hold the map.
I wouldn't say that she's that dove.
Yeah.
Okay.
What's everyone's positions?
Where is everyone on the ship?
He's probably got the highest intelligence on the group.
Probably.
Lin is going to set up his like chemicals and all of that at the corner here.
Unless, unless anyone else wants to be at that home, I guess, Saffelia will be at that home.
Right.
You just at the handle of the ship and you're just moving the handle.
Like.
Roma, what's you doing?
Red, what are you doing?
Baptiste.
Do I have a fish?
Should the fire of the fish and pull out just be off the side just fishing?
Yeah.
You should have probably bought.
I don't think of that.
I want to be in the kitchen.
Is there a kid go behind like in beneath like their Saffelia standing.
There's probably a kitchen inside those.
Yeah.
I'll just be like.
There's no way that we're stealing.
I'm going around the ship.
I'm just letting everyone see if you have way.
Right.
I have.
They've already seen that I have wings.
Yeah.
Okay.
Baptiste is just flying around the ship.
Red, what are you doing?
Red is taking his position up in the crow's nest.
Yeah.
They're playing their back type music.
The top of the mast and their crow's nest and they're just looking out and just singing.
Please tell me.
Please tell me you're singing black Betty.
On the back.
All right.
So what I'm going to do here because you don't have a navigator.
I'm going to roll for a random encounter.
That random encounter can be against the weather or.
Seekings and let me tell you.
Seeking battle at this point is very deadly.
So.
Fucking.
I guess it type.
I'd say you're.
Yeah.
And I'd say for a couple of days, it's all smooth sailing.
No problems.
But after a couple of days, the weather starts to turn for the worst and let's fucking roll for the random encounter.
Or let me see what the fuck did I put for this.
Oh God.
Okay.
Fuck.
414.
Oh shit.
Okay.
All right.
Let's run it then.
So as you're sailing across, it's still a morning time.
There's nothing out of ordinary, but you see a severe lack of any ships around you.
The ocean is still.
Then you start to hear like basically shaking around the ocean floor.
It's all across around the ocean where you're sailing towards.
You see a shadow pulling up beneath the ship.
You see it move around like a snake, essentially a large snake moving around beneath the ship.
And well, I guess we fucking ball.
It starts raining.
Let me pull up.
What the fuck.
I already forgot.
Staple will tend to turn the ship away from the giant fucking underwater snake that is most likely a seeking.
Yeah, it's gonna keep coming after you.
You would be flying.
You would be flying around.
You probably would have seen the shadow.
It's not immersed yet.
It's still beneath the ship.
And you are also going to run into a fucking storm.
So let me do that.
I might want to land this storm.
Wait, what role even is that?
He is not any role.
I don't think.
I mean, it's Zoro's role, essentially.
So he said he's the quote unquote combatant.
He's the fighter.
Well, and it starts raining.
You see thunder all around you.
And seeking will emerge from.
Right side as it crashes into your ship.
Can everyone make an externality saving throw?
Please.
I'll sappily fill out for fucking four different roles.
I'll flip and make one if I was flying at the time.
No, no, you won't have to if you are flying.
Everyone else make a mystery saving.
Okay, that's an 18 for me.
Yeah, that's good.
Red, you're going to fall off the mast.
Can you make a constitution saving throw for me?
To see if you land properly.
Oh, that's fine.
That's 10 is okay.
Sappilya, you are standing strong.
Nothing's budging you.
The ship is shaking and everything.
And I think it's bothering you.
It's really emerges and it will start to thrash at the ship.
And next gift time.
Yep.
Roll for fucking common conjure.
Why?
I'm throwing over that one.
Oh, my God, red.
This is crazy.
Well, they just landed at the fucking bottom.
Okay, that's fine.
Bob, this role for initiative.
Why is my thing?
Oh, damn.
How long would we have they traveling for?
For three days, Elsa.
So you're almost.
Okay, during that time could Sappilya have done her roles for her box?
Yeah, I'll make you do the roles at the end of the session today.
And could she have studied a diggett dial and maybe possibly a way she could refill it?
Probably not because it will require like propane or some of that stuff,
which I don't I don't think you can just make.
You need some life.
Not like her refill in it, but like her figure out, oh, I could refill this.
Can you do us straight intelligence?
Yep.
Intelligence chef.
Yeah.
You know what? Maybe Lynn will help you with that.
So do an advantage.
Did you do it?
I'm not me.
Yeah, you know the basic components of how you can refill it.
Lynn will probably help you with like the chemical structure of what you exactly need.
But you won't probably won't be able to find any of the components right now.
Yeah, actually, all right.
All right.
First is that piece.
You see this monstrous beast emerge as you're flying around.
So but again, if you if they hit you and you hit the water,
you're gonna start drowning.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, just be a little bit.
I'm wrong.
I think.
I am going to lie around just to make sure that I am.
Above the ship.
All right.
And this is going to be so much work and still put in there right?
Yeah, yeah.
You circle around the beast and that's probably your movement and you can start attacking.
Wow.
That will let me see.
That will hit him.
Yeah, that will hit him.
Unfortunately.
Yeah.
Okay, as you fly around,
you will land a punch on him.
I'm going to do six amounts of damage.
Do the beast as it thrashes around.
The next is.
Hold on.
I want to clear your clothes.
Okay.
All right.
Damn.
Gang that most boats.
I have both of them don't hit.
Why is it minus four?
It's the knockout punch.
No, why is the role having minus four in it?
It's because the role suppose.
I'm going to do it.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Next is Roma.
Is he close enough where I stand like.
How do you do this?
Like right next to him on the ship.
I'm going to do it.
Let me see.
Yeah, he's like literally like crying on the ship.
I want to move right here.
Right.
I'm swinging for the fence.
All right, there you go.
Request attack.
All right.
That hits him.
Okay.
So you pull out your skillet and you just bash into the cross that is
crying on the ship with next is the beast and he is going to do a multi-attack.
And he's going to bite two of you.
Let me attack first and then I'll decide who it will be.
Probably the cold closest one would just be.
Does it 24 hit you?
Baptiste.
Yeah, probably.
I don't know why I'm asking.
He's going to attack Baptiste and he's going to attack Roma because they're the closest.
Normal.
The damage.
Baptiste will take half of that damage because of you know what?
I don't want to tell anyone as the beast claws through Baptiste.
You see a flutter of just like when you're walking on the road and there's like you know some kind of heat coming through that.
You see that essentially as the beast claw bites through him.
He will take six amount of damage and Roma will take or Jesus Christ 17.
I should have given the 17 to him.
Yeah, that should have been eight for you.
Can you minus two?
I think yeah, the first one should hit Baptiste in the second one with Roma.
Roma will take 12 amount of damage.
Let me do that here.
You see the range?
Roma.
Yeah, and Baptiste will take eight amount of damage.
So I'm going to do minus two again.
16.
All right, next is.
Sapya.
All right, I shall move up to punch it myself.
All right.
So I'll make it.
I'll make one of my guests in the tax.
Thunderblades.
All right.
The damage.
24 that hits him.
11th under damage.
11th, but he's also vulnerable, right?
Let me see.
Damage vulnerability is lightning, but why is it not increasing the attack?
Does it not increase the attack?
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going to apply 11.
Yeah, I think just make it 22 damage taken.
11 more.
All right.
Oh, I didn't forgot to do this.
As you punch through, that was just the one right.
You want to do another content?
Yeah, I'll do a bonus action.
Punch.
That does not hit him.
So as you punch through one of the gauntlets, the charge from one of the gauntlets surges
through and just electrifies the seeking.
All right.
Next is red.
I can move it to stand up and everybody good.
You want to try to bang this guy?
All right.
Bane is applied.
Let me make a charisma saving throw for the beast.
Yeah, he fails.
Okay.
Bane is applied.
That's a bonus action.
Cheers.
Party expression.
Let's give that to Roma.
All right.
Roma, you have plus six on any role you want to use it on.
Okay.
All right.
Is that your turn?
Actually, no.
Yeah, yeah.
Move back.
Probably good idea.
All right.
Next is Baptiste.
I'm just going to flurry of blows one more time.
I'm going to be knocked out shrinks.
All right.
Really going for broke here.
Nope.
That does not hit.
Rose again.
He is going to fall.
Now, you have your flying movement.
And for flying, I'd say you have you don't have you don't
provoke any opportunity at the act.
So you can try to move away if you want.
You're going to fly 20 feet up high in the air from right now.
All right.
Straight up or.
Yeah, straight up.
Straight up.
You have your in your token.
You have like elevation.
So I'm going to put it at 20.
Okay.
Oh, Lin is not in the fucking.
Let me just add him in the god damn it.
I forgot about Lin.
But he can't really see in the darkness either.
So.
He missed one turn.
He can heal Roma in the meantime.
He will go run up to Roma and try to heal him with which one.
Who is on low?
Baptiste or Roma?
Roma is pretty low.
And I don't he can reach me 20 feet in the air.
Yeah, I don't think I can.
Yeah.
The me heal Roma for legendary actions.
I don't understand.
He uses fucking his legendary actions for healing that said.
Plus eight to Roma.
All right.
That's Lin's small.
Baptiste is that your turn right?
Yeah.
Roma to you.
Yeah, I'm going to start raising because I just took that.
That blow that I'm I'm swinging again.
To the tech.
That will hit him.
Perfect.
Oh, nice.
That's 11 damage to him.
As you go into raid, you start just smashing your skillet into the hands of the sea king.
It's a sinking stern and he is going to do.
If it's again.
Okay, he's going to leap and jump from this side to this side.
And the ship will move a bit and I need all of you guys to do.
Dexterity saving throw.
Lenin succeeding red not is not succeeding red is not succeeding Roma is not succeeding.
Baptiste won't be affected.
He's in the air.
Yeah, let me read what it does.
Oh God.
Oh, that's who survives this except for Baptiste.
It will hit everyone.
Oh, fucking.
I have to do this manually.
Come on.
Is it all.
Bludgeoning.
Oh, damn it.
Okay, I'm moving Baptiste for a second because I can't.
Let me.
Next is.
Len again.
Okay, you also left Bane, I think.
Bane is lifted.
Let me remove that from here.
Okay, I'm going to go.
Time for Len.
Jesus Christ, who needs my help?
Sorry.
I have a house because he's.
I mean, I'm just because he's raging, right?
You're still not you down the nine.
And red is also almost gone.
So who needs my help?
Me and red.
Yeah, I'll probably go grab a red.
I'll read.
All right.
Red, move away just wearing the view in the front line.
It's going to be plus eight to red.
If that's a seeking makes an attack against a red, it will have disadvantage.
Why?
Like, let me just double check the word and but from my thunder fists.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, that's fine.
But the will it to.
I'm going back for just the blood.
Okay.
Let me.
That's Lens turn and he's probably going to move a bit back here once he heals red.
It's your turn.
Right.
Sableil charge on forward to go and punch this fucker in the face.
That would not hit him.
All right.
I will use my I'll use my bonus action to punch again.
All right, try again.
That head hits him.
Do the damage.
I'm not great damage.
Yeah, I'll do five more.
All right, it takes 10 damage.
Next is red.
Ready to move.
If you want to risk it, he will just if you want to risk it, the sea king will have disadvantage on
the opportunity to attack you.
So if you want to use your action for something else.
Please, anybody else comes out.
Thanks for your quickly only plans change.
Forget, let's just go for damage.
Try shatter.
All right, shatter.
He will fail the shatter.
The constitution saving throw.
38 hundred damage rate.
Do that.
Let me apply that.
That's eight plus eight with the thunder again.
And plus eight is three.
28.
All right.
I'll just see right there.
You can fly up if you want to.
That's fine.
Next is the piece.
You're still flying on the right side of the ship.
We're about to do a dive.
All right.
It's going to happen this time.
Okay.
Let's see if the sense of.
I'm going to fly in.
You really quick on the top of that.
Right to slash.
If I hit any of my attempts,
actually before I get to add.
What what melee weapon do you have on you that you're going to like?
Do you have any melee weapon?
Let me check.
If I can't use it with an army,
I won't use it.
No, no, you can't.
I don't know.
I won't use it.
I'm going to crunches.
Again, okay.
Let's go.
That does not hit.
Oh, my god.
I don't think he's.
I don't think it's mathematically possible.
You have minus four on every role.
Oh,
well, you will throw three times.
Congratulations, you jinxed it.
Well, all right.
Do the damage for the last one.
Crit damage.
Crit damage plus 10 with your thing.
Okay, that's 21.
What the fuck plus 10 is 31.
Does actually kill him.
Yeah, that actually can.
What, what, how do you want to end this?
What, the plus 10 is included in the role.
So you don't have to add first thing to it.
Oh, is it?
Oh, it is, it is.
Okay, never mind.
He's not dead.
But what do you do?
Explain to me what do you do?
Mainly from where I was.
Really dope, um, punching.
The first thing is,
with that last one,
you just chill with all his energy
and throw that last guy,
and then you just punch and just rock him.
All right, as you dive bomb into him,
you will take 21 damage.
All right, next is,
is that your moment?
Yeah, I think that's your moment and your turn.
Let me,
so are you going to land or are you still hovering?
I'm going back to where I was.
You said it's a,
I'm throwing the air just not.
All right, all right.
I'm in the background.
Next is Roma.
I think Roma is going to get the fucking kill again.
I'm going to move right underneath him,
and you know it.
You have better good inspiration still.
Yeah, how do I use that?
Just just say you want to add six to the.
Yeah, I'm you.
I'm doing the reckless attack.
Oh, that's a crit.
All right, let's go.
Let me see.
Will that actually kill him?
Yeah, that will kill him.
Okay, so as Baptiste just dive bombs into the sea king,
he takes the lead.
So as Baptiste just dive bombs into the sea king,
he takes like a whole chunk of his right side of the body
and just blood dripping out.
He has no mobility on the right side.
And Roma, you're going to, how do you, how do you want to finish this?
I'm a bit home run swinging it.
I'm swinging for the fence.
I'm cracking him.
As you come in in pure rage,
just seeing fish in front of you,
you will just smack the hell out of the sea beast.
As it like falls down slowly,
you will just hit him in the head.
And he's dead.
Oh, my God.
The blood from the sea beast is leaking on into the sea.
And yeah, he's going to start sinking.
And then maybe after some time, it's starting floating again.
I'm going to be like anybody wants sushi.
All right, welcome back.
I, Lynn goes up and his leg,
I told you when you need a fucking navigator.
But I guess we made out of it.
Made it out of this alone.
Anyone else trying to be a navigator right now, no, do I?
Oh, no, no.
Yeah.
You see just blood spatters all across the ship.
As it, as you come out of the storm.
I think we're going to have a good time.
We're going to have a good time.
You're going to have a good time.
are they poisonous? They got a poison sack? No. There's only one way to know. Do you want to eat
something? That would be a nature or would that be history? Uh, I'd say it would be nature here.
You can't you can't tell if it's poison or not. It is it is a serpent type in the
art of this and you can set it for poison I guess. Uh, you can take a blood blood
wild but the results will take some time. Hey, you cannot tell the images. I'm just going
to keep cutting. All right. Uh, Lynn is going to come here take a blood sample out of the
fucking pool of blood that's flowing through the ship and he's going to go back and put it in like
one of his like, what are those called fucking spinning things? Yeah, the measure. He's gonna
put it in one of those strange trifusual whatever devices and it's going to just keep running. Yeah.
All right. What next?
I ain't gonna lie to you. I want to take a fat break.
Or whatever. Like I'm fucked up. Yeah, yeah. I'd say like it's like maybe eight more
hours till you reach Spirit Cliffs so you can take a break or long rest until you reach Spirit Cliffs.
Just do it or long rest so we can just start from that and then we do Spirit Cliffs next session.
I mean, oh, he didn't even hit Lynn once.
Yeah, probably a little rough stuff. No, I guess he did. Oh, the the the leap thing that did hit him.
Yeah, sadly, I will. You can make it her way towards Spirit Cliffs at the helm.
All right. I'm going to be sleeping and feeding people. As soon like things try start to calm down a bit.
I'm going to say you completely salvage the CB's. I'm going to remove the fucking blood. Who's cleaning the
fucking ship? For getting a new one in the morning. No one can cook it. Get no one's
fucking cleaning the ship. Okay. That means already has enough jam rolls on this ship.
So what else? Clean it. We put the blood back then. I guess no one's fucking cleaning.
Lynn's cleaning. It's bothering Lynn. Okay, fucking. The doctor sure. He's gonna
either one who took the least amount of damage, because that's the one cleaning the ship.
You know what? What I'm what I'm going to do is he's going to say the rest of the body parts and
the blood. He's going to see that. He's going to say, okay, everyone get away.
He's going to come in the middle where the body parts were and he's just going to touch the seeking
and the blood, whatever. And he's going to just phase the ship out of the fucking thing. It just
sinks in the ocean below. I'm never going to do that. Again, okay, I'm not your worker. I'm just
here temporarily. I was just bothering you. He was just bothering me. So I just did it. Okay.
Don't think this is a regular activity. I'm not sure fucking made.
All right. As soon as you clear out the area, the ship is looking fine. You hear the mirror
then then machine go off. Who has the damage machine? Exactly.
Exactly. I get to call him the damage machine. Yeah.
All right. She'll pick it up and begin whispering in her armor.
You you hear from the other side?
Sapplya, is that you? Yep, it's me. Are you on your way to Spirit Cliffs?
Yep. Well, they're pretty soon. All right. I don't know if trade told you or not, but Spirit Cliffs
has a marine base. Okay. So be careful. And I don't think. I just got disconnected from how.
Okay. What were you saying?
It has a marine base. Yeah. So you probably cannot take your armor there. Okay.
All righty then. All right. Is Baptiste with you? I heard he left the ranks and he ran towards
Kuro. Yep. We picked him up on the way. All right. Can you pass me to Baptiste?
Oh yeah, sure. Where it can be heard in armor as
Sapplya calls out to Baptiste. And Baptiste? Here's got to call for you.
Not just what's up. Fine.
All right. As Baptiste lands and he will pick up the then machine. Mirror will go.
I see you made it there somehow. Did you doubt I would? Well, yeah. Do you think that can
won't tell me? Anyway, can you move away from it? I wanted to talk to you too in private.
Gotcha. I'll take the machine to fly up. Yeah. As you're flying up, uh, uh,
mirror goes. You keep your wings hidden. You understand? If anyone sees you on your marine base,
it will be problem. I know. Got me.
Well, I got you. We don't want another war going on in the east,
especially with the Marines right now.
Here was hoping we could destroy the base.
Okay. I told a new black. I knew that you were a handful from Black period, but this is insane.
Did you just say fight the Marines in their base?
All right. That's enough. Give me give me hand me back to Sapplya.
Sapplya, Trey told me there was someone with you other than your crew. Who was it?
Oh, yeah. We're bringing a long line.
She's gonna scream through the then and machine. She's gonna go. Linus, you bastard.
You better not get them involved in some of your sixfold bullshit. Okay.
Linus is gonna go. All right. All right. I already know. Okay. I'm just heading to the spirit cliffs.
You sure you did? I heard what was going on there. Are you sure you don't want us or help?
Varyat will most likely he hates you the least out of all the
Black hands commanders. He probably will try to help you.
The okay, I'm all over the fucking voice.
He will.
Yeah, Varyat will try to help you if you need his help.
Are you sure you would all want to put in a good word?
By me. Sapplya, Mira goes. No, you bastard. You stay away from them and get off at
spirit cliffs and never see us again. Linus is gonna go. All right. I'm fucking sure.
Sapplya is, Sapplya still has the thing, right? And she's gonna go. Roma, I heard you,
Mira, Mira will go. Roma, I heard you were a bit careless. Okay. Try to calm down a bit.
All right. We can't go around killing people all the time.
This is where I'll be like, they didn't want my food. I offered. I politely asked. Okay.
You don't want my food. Look, Roma, I understand. I understand your problem, but
you have to understand. We can't just go around killing people. We're no better than other parrots.
Okay. Hey, he's swung on me first. I can't help it. If he swung on you, that's fine. But try to
restrain yourself. Okay. I can't promise. All right. She's gonna ask you to hand her over to Red now.
Yep. I have an Sapplya old dude now. All right.
Red, are you there? All right. You will take your Denlin machine to the crow's nest. Probably,
right? Sure. All right. As you have the Denlin machine there, mirror will whisper to you.
We send some of your old crew around Spirit Clips. Yeah. Try to be careful.
I know you don't probably remember them, but we've heard that tusksmen have been going around
near Spirit Clips. Just be aware. And if something happens, just try to dissolve the situation
of the rather than fight. Okay. We can't. We can't have another war on us. Not again. More and no.
Red just kind gets a far away looking his eyes up and I'd show the name us and just kind of
nod even though, really, but she can't hear that.
Yeah. Miracles. I'm gonna take that as a yes. Yeah. Give me back to Sapplya. I want to tell her what to do next
after Spirit Clips. Sapplya and kind of flutters back down to Sapplya.
All right. I talked to Bramble this morning. Okay. The thing is, he has a ship, but he probably won't
hand you that easily. He probably will have you run some errands. As far as I've known him,
it's not gonna be easy. Okay. But if it's too much, you better, if it's too much, you try to be careful.
It's your crew now. If they die, that's on you. You understand?
I know. All right. Well, the plan is essentially what I'm dealing with right now, it's much of a headache
and I do need backup. So as soon as you can get here, which will probably take a while,
if you're not going through the Campbellt, okay. I'll try it. I'll try it as Bramble if they can give
you a ship that can travel through the Campbellt. If not, then you'll have to journey all through the
Gantleine to get here. All right. So go through the Gantleine, sorry, go through the reverse mountain,
add to the Gantleine. If you have a ship that does handle Campbellt properly,
cross the Campbellt into the south. All right. If not, then I guess you go through the Gantleine and
exit out at the end of it. Sounds good. All right. I can try to hire a navigator here. I heard the
little guy left. Yep. I've been learning to navigate now. Okay. That's good. Okay. Sure.
Well, she's going to cut it off right there and she's going to just end it with,
I'll let you be careful. And then she's going to cut it off. All right. I think that was a good two
hours. Exactly. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Pretty exactly two hours. Yeah. All right.
Next session, I already have like most of it planned. So it's going to be pretty simple.
I want to try a couple of things like playing around with like cards and stuff and all that.
So if anyone's available at like within the week, let me know. I want to test some stuff out. And
let me roll those checks for the box. Yeah. Yeah. Three days. So that's six rolls. Yep.
No one will be able to help this, but that's fine. That's 20. Let's go.
Hell yeah. One more. Yep. Yep.
Second one probably. Yeah. That's good. That's again. And that's when Jesus Christ.
All right. You're five. Oh my god. That's 16. That's fine.
Five. Two more. Oh, that's 20. Yeah.
Uh, one more. Was it one, two, three, four, five, six? No. Okay. Okay. No, that's it. Uh, you will
successfully turn like some pieces and it will fit four. Three more. So that last
was like two, two plus one, two, three, four, four, six. Yeah. You're six out of 100. And
all right. Maybe I try to update the item sheet so you can keep track of everything.
Everyone has their items figured out, right? Anything that I need to add. I think the tone dials
I need to give, right? Yep. Uh, what else? What else? I'm missing any item that I'll not give
any way. Uh, no, red has their armor. Uh, no one else really got anything else, right?
I thought red traded the armor. Uh, yeah, they sold the armor and then got one started one back, right?
Okay. What? Uh, I'd start stars and wishes. What do you think?
I sent it last time. I don't know who replied. I actually didn't check a lot. Did I send it to
RTC? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Uh, it's happily enrollment like. So what do you guys think for
this one? Stars and wishes for the next time. Stars for this one. Favorite thing that happened
and wish that you want to happen for the next time. Favorite moment for me is my dive bomb.
Yeah, the dive bomb was very, very crazy. That somehow had
a real gamble. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Well, because I missed every other hit.
But which one is fine? Including.
Sorry? I'm currently working with both NPCs. Yeah, yeah.
A navigator. Oh, man. I don't happen again. Yeah. Red, what'd you would you think?
Now, sapling will just learn how to be a navigator a lot on the ground.
We'll see. We'll see. Yeah, good session. Yeah, do you think anything that you liked
in the session? What are you looking forward to the next session?
I'll probably just type it out in chat later. Got tired.
All right. Yeah, you can head out. I think it's pretty late for you anyway. All right, Roma?
Yeah. Uh, favorite thing, you know, getting the kill.
Can't help it. Sure. It happens. Uh, things to happen
for wishes. Yeah. Do it don't matter. I'm up for anything. All right. Cool.
It's out there. She got it. I liked, uh, sapling. I happened to fucking start learning how to
be a damn navigator now. Nice. And hoping, uh, sapling makes more progress on the puzzle box
next session. All right. Let's see. We'll see. I mean, it's going to take a while. Maybe
if you enter the ground line, we'll see. We'll see. I'm, there's like a couple of options for ships
depending on what you guys do in the birdclips. Based on that, I'll do the next sessions.
But yes, birdclips going to take a while. It's probably a full arc of things that's going to go
away. You will learn more about like Linus and the six falls that Mira was talking about.
Yeah. All right. Good session, guys.
All right. Good night.
I'll see you all next Saturday, same time.
You
you